I invited 60 YouTubers to compete in the
world's hardest challenge and whoever is
the last remaining wins a Times Square
billboard for 24 hours our first
challenge is red light green light but
this time the boys are going to be
shooting them with lasers have fun
run go go go go go go go go go go
oh it's green light I didn't know oh I'm
gonna show that oh Mom moved way after
oh no I forgot to remember it's gonna be
me you're not the first one to go out
that's embarrassing all right green
lights
I'm dead first the boys could only shoot
their lasers when it's screen light why
did Amy at me oh me man you better not
move that's George yo kill him right now
everyone let's make sure George doesn't
get this billboard oh I'm ready three
two one
[Music]
wait why there we go they're like we got
nine minutes we'll just hang out
I gotta pee turn it green dude we've
been saying so for a long time it's
literally been a minute we're running
out of time green light I'm gonna let
this one run
oh my gosh oh my gosh
that was so fast I don't care if I don't
make the next one it's just really sad
if you lose first round boys aim on
someone I'm a set of green in three two
one
yeah I'm gonna tell them I'm gonna
switch the green light but not switch it
green light yeah any man boys okay three
two one boom
ah
so we got three minutes and hardly any
space left I could just trap these
people here forever let's see who's left
we got socks for one
I wonder if they're freaking out
Rizzy all the way in the back my worst
fear is that I'm gonna end up in last
and like oh this guy is last let's kill
him yeah I think we shoot Rizzy all
right
oh they killed me I'll see you later
Rizzy just not in Times Square I'm gonna
stop right before they get to it
we got a minute and a half I want to
show you my cool toy I just got oh my
God no it's not The Clapper is it it is
I wanted to show them
because they didn't last bro yo Mr B's I
don't really care about your little toy
huh there's only 30 seconds left Jimmy
all right here I feel like we should hit
it
oh yeah
[Music]
I don't know how I didn't die I'm on the
edge I'm so close I'm gonna wait for the
dramatic wall to come
turn green bro it's coming when can I go
okay I don't know if it's gonna hit him
or not
let's go
oh
oh what oh Reese's now Reese's and after
challenge number one we are down to 35
people let's head to the next one the
next challenge is a giant obstacle
course the first 20 people to make it
past the lasers lavas and Avalanche move
on to the next round server star
Challenge number two
this is our territory
no the I
once you cross these green things over
here if you die that's where you respawn
[Music]
I think I'm fast this guy is so far
ahead he's in the volcano
they make so much progress and then you
knock them back honestly this is my
favorite thing I've ever done
oh I'm graved oh no oh my gosh he just
killed me with a bow directly we jumped
onto that Arrow if I'm these guys I hate
me right now
oh you like me all the way across
they're locked away thank you oh that
person made it who's locked to the board
I'm at the log pot all right so we got
stocks for one we got player 298 I'm
going right side that's a fuss
no I got logged
I could see the top please man I'm
begging oh they're gonna make it
all right we had our first finish one
out of 20.
we're qualified bro I'm close
he diced me bro yo you're getting
screwed you're so far back I'm all the
way at the start oh if I can make it if
I can make it if I can make it yo I got
shot down the map
I'm going I'm going sorry to get this
yellow guy Target this yellow guy bro
please oh my God this guy's so close to
the Finish
yes
mystery I'm gonna storm the mountain
with you we can do it
please don't
I just want to let all of you know that
there's only five slots left don't
forget that at Times Square billboard is
on the line no it's over if you don't
get up this hill you're not gonna be on
a Times Square billboard three people
just died in front of me bro let me help
you out with this Shockwave
let's go oh that actually did help
somebody
again oh
all 20 of you over here congrats you're
moving on next challenge now I split the
remaining players into two teams and
each side has been armed with an
explosive weapon the last team standing
moves on server bring out the two guns
oh shoot go go go go
away
come on guys shoot him
no I died I'm out further back further
back shoot further back their base is
melting away in front of our eyes
whenever I press this button
the grenade launcher switches hands
shoot it at them shoot it at them shoot
it at them
oh yes nice nice nice pray Olaf prayer
left prayer left
no
come on
no no yes
oh
no oh I'm dead I'm dead I just got three
of them a Times Square billboard is on
the line it's coming down to the wire
it's about even we got this please go
I'm taking him out I'm taking them out
no oh god
oh I found no Sizzle it's up to you I
got this
foreign
team was eliminated congratulations I
know there's 10 of you and only one of
you is winning but if you were to win
what would you put on the billboard
got it welcome to dinner demolition
derby we
seems and you have
you had a final round so don't get blown
up server start the derby
here we go here we go yellow yellow
yellow and throughout this Arena our
golden green orbs which gives you
weapons when you drive over them all
right we're pulling it all over the
place oh purple's in the air purple's in
the air I repeat they can't even shoot
us just keep on doing that
our card is amazing right now oh yellow
car you're done oh wait we just got
klingered We Got Fingered oh
The Flip Flip Flip Flip all right do we
need Tire I I'm trying if you can get me
there I'm in the middle I'm in the
middle oh berserks out oh don't let him
in don't let him in give me the yes
go back I got you yes let's go let's go
let's go let's go
we are taking Mass damage your car is on
fire let me help you chill out I don't
know if that's helping oh your car is
about to blow up oh my God red I'm so
sorry red no oh my god oh red no
we haven't taken damage for a while man
this is the best strap I think we've
been in the airline leave it on the
ground
how's it going gray car
no that is not good leave great car
alone prepare to die
they [ __ ] us
Carl we love you bro please you love me
yes oh let's go mess with yellow hey
yellow yeah what's up man how you doing
prepare to die no no
no
no
no
no
boom yellow is just getting juggled
yellow you guys are struggling yes I'm
at 100 embarrassed I'll give you the
billboard you guys do your thing I'll
leave you to it what do you mean do I
think we're on 24 HP stay still well
we're dead we're dead thanks
thanks Chris GG what oh no that got him
I didn't think it was gonna be the last
one all the remains is green purple and
white we only need to eliminate one more
car hey green car
all I want to do is explode you it's
over if you die don't die agree
oh I hit him this is the end
oh green blew up yes
congratulations you four are moving on
to the final round guess what I'm in
fortnite the outfit I am currently
wearing is officially available in the
fortnite item shop right now and to
celebrate I decided to host an insane
tournament inside of fortnite for 1
million dollars this tournament goes
live tomorrow from noon to 3 P.M Eastern
and anyone no matter where you are in
the world can join this fortnite
tournament and compete for a chance to
win one million dollars and even if you
don't get the number one spot and win
the million dollars we're still gonna be
giving away tons of other prizes to
other high place finishers and don't
worry if you can't make it tomorrow from
noon to 3 P.M Eastern for the live
tournament you can still play the map
after the tournament's finished and my
skin will still be available in the
fortnite item shop which you should
totally go by use code Mr Beast in the
item shop shout out to epic games I had
so much fun collaborating on this
tournament and I can't wait for you guys
to compete in it we put so much freaking
effort into it hopefully you win a
million dollars and for the final
challenge I flew the four remaining
contestants down and we're doing it in
real life fortnite this will be fun I
have no idea what we're doing I'm signed
up for this I'm locked in I'm gonna win
the villain what I don't even care I
have no idea what I'm doing but I'm
gonna win this last challenge is pretty
simple don't die that's the easiest
thing to do last one remaining wins
server start us off with some lightning
lightning
oh no hey watch out for the rain
okay okay I'm in the water I I'm pretty
much dead already bro Ash is already
about to lose it
it's in half already how about we drop
some bombs that sounds really bad don't
do that
I'm on 50 Health that's what happens
don't fall off the platform you just
don't want to be in Times Square server
drop the bumper pins
holder is coming from the back as well
and while those are going activate the
lightning
oh no
good little boys Ash has just gotta be
like one HP now
all the way from England to lose first
Ash more like trash honestly this is
looking a little too easy can we get
those firewalls in here
what the hell are this which way do I
look I also forgot I can shrink the zone
I can only focus on one thing at a time
I can't even focus on one thing should I
shrink it more streak one more this
let's make this very very hard turn on
the lightning no no no no no no no no
it's too much
I fell off oh they all took a ton of
damage right there all right how much
health do you have 450. I have 335. I
got 730. try mixes in last place oh this
is not good this is not good all right
sucks do I shrink the zone or more
lightning
oh no I've been here I've been hit you
knew I was about to shrink it what was
that for there's so many things
happening at once I say we go even
smaller you know what fun this is
literally give me one block
oh I can't believe they all clutched
that you know what reset the hexagons I
want to give them more space Oh I think
you should totally go to the outer edge
but yeah I almost did I was walking
towards it all right fine fine this time
you should totally go stand on the pink
squares don't listen to them it's got to
be a bait It's gotta be
trimix flew all the way from Austria to
lose second
socks how are you feeling do you think
you're gonna win dude I'm feeling so
confident but at the same time I'm
awfully low all right server start
spamming random things random things oh
God avoid the bumps shock stay away from
the ball
gang no no no
yes let's go what do you want to put on
the Times Square billboard uh I'm gonna
self-promise actually let's just go to
it dude this is insane I can't believe
the water billboard
[Music]